Mentor B: شباب سامعيني كويس من جنيف،
Mentor B: شباب.
Learner B5: أيوا سطوة.
N.Learner B4: فرن.
Mentor B: الحمد لله.
N.Learner B4: كل زايد. الحمد لله.
Mentor B: كده واضح عندي شوية.
N.Learner B4: أوكي.
Mentor B: أوكي ماشي خلينا نبتدي.
N.Learner B4: يلا مينا ده لاست حلو.
Mentor B: ان شاء الله بس اقول لكم كده لو في حاجة يعني ممكن حاجات تانية نكمل يعني فيها يعني بس هي ممكن تبقى بس احنا نتواصل على السويس لو في حاجة يعني.
N.Learner B4: أكيد أكيد كيف حالك.
Mentor B: حلو قوي ماشي عندنا في أكتيڤيتي كنت عايز أعمله كدا معاكو
Mentor B: دي اول حاجة تاني حاجة كنت حتكلم عن حاجة كنت تكلمت عليها في الجوبل التاني بس ما تكلمتش معاه معكم عليها
Mentor B: بخصوص في السجن وكدا، وتالت حاجة يعني نبتدي بيها إنتو لو عندكوا أسئلة معينة
Mentor B: في في الويك ده عايز أسمع منك أقطار استفدتوا تعلمتوا كانت حاجاتي قدامكواش حياتي.
N.Learner B4: بالنسبة لي أنا ما فيش حاجة معينة في الصراحة يعني الجزء الخاص ببزنس ده شوية يعني يمكن
N.Learner B4: طبيعة شغلي محاماني حابة فمريو.
N.Learner B4: بس أنا وأنا شغالة الوي ده أحس إننا عايزة أغير حاجات في الويك في اللي فات يعني عايز أغير عايز أعمل شوية عايزة أعمل لايك
N.Learner B4: مختلفة لكل حاجة لحاجات معينة عملتها في
N.Learner B4: يعني لو أنا مش غلطان عادي إني أرجع البروتوتي طيب اعدل ولا دي حاجة فيها مشكلة.
Mentor B: لا طبعا لما تمشي قدام بتكون عايز حتى تعدل المشكلة اللي انت وصلت لها فهي مهتمة عايزة يعني ترجعي وتبصي تعدلي يعني الاحساس ده جالك ازاي.
N.Learner B4: أنا آيديا بتاعة أو في أنا شفت إن إحنا المشكلة
N.Learner B4: يعني خليني أرجع خاطر وأرى في الكلام شوية أنا عادة لما أبص لمشكلة في الشركة ما بحاولش أطلع ما بين ال يعني يعني ما فيش إن أنا ما فيش أسر من أنا أقول طيب أنا دلوقتي مثلا على سبيل المثال، إسمي
N.Learner B4: بروتوك مانجمنت أو بروتوك مانجر وعشان كدا مش بيطلع الفيتورز بتاعتي
N.Learner B4: الحل أنا عين برودكتمنتش ولو في ألريدي بادجت ده ويكون دوت إيزي ستوريف إني بريديت
N.Learner B4: واي إز إن إنت عندي ريسورسيس وأنا إزاي ريسورسيس دي وتويك بحيث إن أنا
N.Learner B4: أقصى حاجة منه. أقدر إننا أحققه.
Mentor B: الوعود.
N.Learner B4: اللي أنا كنت شايفاه إن المشكلة مش إني أنا أحط منتورز كتير
N.Learner B4: إحنا عايزين نبدأ يعني كرؤيتي سبرينتس أنا الإي آي دلوقتي ببقى في كل حاجة والإيه آي ده الشخص الشاطر منصف الشاطر اللي يقدر يخلي يختصر عليه طرق كتير.
Mentor B: حلو.
N.Learner B4: نشتغل عليه فهل هي المشكلة؟ مافيش مينترز هي المشكلة فيرست وان احنا سيتيشنز
N.Learner B4: مكانش واضحة السكن فين إن أنا عندي ال إي آي إيجنس
N.Learner B4: مش حقدر أقول فاين تونينج عشان ده شوية كوستري بس
N.Learner B4: أعمله فينغ وأبدأ أشتغل معاه إن هو فروم ذي مين
N.Learner B4: اللي عندي بتاعتهم على فأنا لما أجي أتكلم معاي بفهم؟ أنا بتكلم في
N.Learner B4: الساجنتينج إن هو يكون أنا مش عايزة أتكلم مع حد وأوصل لحتة. إن أنا لو الحاجة دي مش عارفة الإيه آي أوكي خلاص ليتس ريزلت تيكيت تو ذي مينتور دايريكت
N.Learner B4: فيوصل للمنتور التكتله على فيدباك آي غوتون. سأسأله ليه فيدباك عن حالته أشوف غوتون ثيس أنسور ثيس أون تو سكاي ألريدي
N.Learner B4: إن نوميدي اللي عنده الخاصة فأنا أعمل للإي أوي أنا في الباك إندومات هوب ده حيخلي بالنسبالنا إكسبيرينس أحسن
N.Learner B4: بكتير فأنا مش هواجه مشكلة من داي يكون عندي تايم واين لأي ريسبونس يعني مثلا تذكر بعد أسبوع أو 10 أيام
N.Learner B4: بعد ساعتين تلاتة الوركينغ أورز بتاعتي عاملة ازاي عبال لأني شايف الحاجة دي الحاجة التانية كنت شفتها إن أنا في أكثر. من منتور. أنا مش عارف مين باد على فين أنا فور وات أنا مش عارف
N.Learner B4: آي فود وين آي توك ويث أل إيفينج إننا أبقى ألريدي فولي أوير.
Mentor B: نور.
N.Learner B4: هذا.
Mentor B: شكرا.
N.Learner B4: فده هو بالظبط اللي أنا عايز أعمله في إن أنا مش عايز أغير الإي آي عشان عندي بس أنا عايز إن أنا أستفاد قدر الإمكان عن اللي عندي وما خلوش أنا مش عايزة.
Mentor B: حلو حلو طيب انت ممكن انتي اعمالي أوي فهو مش شاطي يبان فيه فهمتي نخلي التشاب بوينت
Mentor B: يعني اللي احنا عندنا مش بسبب المشاكل اللي انت قلتيها اللي انت بتوصبيها ولا لسه ما قربتيش حاجة زي كدا.
N.Learner B4: معليش الصوت ويقطع.
Mentor B: من فإنه إزاي تحولي الكونتويشن لي أوي للي انت عايزاه دوت.
N.Learner B4: بالظبط ده اللي أنا اشتغلت عليه هو كان عنده تو وايز الويه صلحلي كان في حاجة اسمها فاين تونينج
N.Learner B4: ودي حاجة شوية ادفانت. أو إنها حتبتدي بقى وحاجات
N.Learner B4: وحاجات زي كده أنا عايز أسهل وأرخص كتير
N.Learner B4: الحاجة التانية. إن أنا أعمل أعمل عندي
N.Learner B4: الأولاني الخاص بالكوندريس لكل بروجرام، فأنا هيبقى عندي الأسماء 2 وكان
N.Learner B4: محمد حاتم ان هو ألريدي حيبقى عنده كل 1 من هو يقدر يتكلم معاك بنفس ال بيرسونالتي 4 يكون هو في عنده متقسمة الخاصة ب سبيرتينس.
Mentor B: من اسبوعين كمل.
N.Learner B4: فهي هي القصة كده القصة إن أنا أقدر إن أنا لما أتكلم معاه أنا بتكلم مع حد هو فاهم أنا بتكلم
N.Learner B4: هي بس كل الموضوع مش شبه بالظبط نفسي.
Mentor B: من.
N.Learner B4: دلوقتي.
Mentor B: أكتب عالجبيتي.
N.Learner B4: هو.
Mentor B: أسألك سؤالين ده.
N.Learner B4: الطريقة سبيسيفيكلي لسه الصراحة مش قادرة أديك طريقة معينة أقدر أنفذها بس أنا ألريدي يعني عندي ميتينغ مع حد يوم السبت
N.Learner B4: شغلت حتل إي إنجينيرينغ ده فحاول أفهم منه إزاي الدنيا تكون تتحل عملية مش نظرية.
Mentor B: فرنش.
N.Learner B4: بس الأيدي اللي عندي انا ان هو الموضوع حيبقى شبه عندي مشكله كذا هو الكلام اللي كنا نتكلم فيه قبل كده ويبدا يظهر لي رده
N.Learner B4: إمم.
Mentor B: أوكي.
N.Learner B4: وده اللي إحنا محتاجينه وجهة نظري.
Mentor B: وعود لا لا، أنا مبسوط يعني
Mentor B: اقولك انا اديكي نقطتين أولا، ندى ثانك يو مبهر وأنا منبهة بي
Mentor B: وتصوره يعني هو كومبليجيتد فصعب يعني انتي شاطرة انتي وصلتينه سريعا يعني هو اعتقد مؤذن يعني
Mentor B: لا يعني ده مجهود واقع
Mentor B: بس عايز أقولك بقى يعني هنا اللي انت عملتيه احنا بنتكلم بقى انت عملتي اطفال يعني انا حكلمك بقى
Mentor B: فهمتي الذي انتي عملتيه لا يعني انتي عملتيه عشان اديكي بتاعتي.
N.Learner B4: نعم.
Mentor B: في حاجتين فيدباك اشياء لكن هذه ليست حاجات
Mentor B: نواقص او فلوس في التسول لأ دي حاجات
Mentor B: انا بقى يعني عشان أنا عديت قبل كده محتج اقولك طب انا بقى اللي خلي بالك منه ان شاء الله عشان لما.
N.Learner B4: إن شاء الله.
Mentor B: حتة حتة دي حتة فيها وأنا كنت بتكلم فيها لا انه هو لازم تكون تصوراتي مرتبطة اللي عندي
Mentor B: لو الشباب فاكرين فمتفق معاكي فيها بس ياريت تكون معاه ممكن يبقى خاسر في حيطلعها.
N.Learner B4: أم.
Mentor B: فانت، فأنت محتاج. انت محتاجة تكون بالانست جدا بين يا جماعة الحاجات دي وفيها اكشن ستحتاجي لا، انا محتاج
Mentor B: وهنا لا خلط لأن هو كده كده السيليسيز المراية دي مش حيبقى
Mentor B: فهي دي بقى نقطة في اي حاجة يعني في وأنا
Mentor B: حيتحل ولا لأ أنا محتاج أضغط عشان ما أعمل غلطة دي قبل كدا
Mentor B: عملت سينوشن نص طن ولا ربعكم وبعدين
Mentor B: عشان أنا كنت ملتزم خطوات وقلت لها يا جماعة معين ألس كان ده حيحصل
Mentor B: فاهمين فهي النقطة دي يعني النقطة دي على قد ما هي حلوة على قد منعتها ممكن في بعض الأشياء
Mentor B: وما طلبت ماشي دي اول حاجة عندك أي فيدباك عليها متفقة ولا في أي فيدباك.
N.Learner B4: لا لا موقفكم جدا هو مش شرط غير سوزس كلها بس وفي نفس الوقت،
N.Learner B4: مش شرط. إن أنا أعمل أحسن حاجة في الدنيا فاهمة جدا.
Mentor B: ماشي حرام الحاجة الثانية تركيزك هو على فكرة بتاعة الحتة دي عشان تبقى
Mentor B: بس أنا يعني كنت يعني ده جامد جدا حلو
Mentor B: بس هولك على حاجة إحنا حسألكوا سؤال هو مين الانجح دلوقتي شايفينه في الواقع.
N.Learner B4: في اللحظة اللي إحنا فيها دي كلود.
Mentor B: ، ماشي حلو ون
Mentor B: يا ساتر ياسر.
Learner B3: أنا مش متأكدة بس حاسة برضه كلود دلوقتي فعلا شائع يعني.
Mentor B: حلو.
Mentor B: أهلا يا سالم
Mentor B: انت عايز أسميه فور أون سومان
Mentor B: أوكي مشاورنا في الشتاء
Mentor B: ماشي تمام ف دلوقتي احنا بنتكلم فكرة طب مريم ماشي مريم مريم انتو ليه شايفين كروت أنجح حاجة دلوقتي
Mentor B: بسم الله.
Learner B3: من ضمن الحاجات إن هو ممكن يشتغل ومش لازم يكون الشخص قاعد معاي يعني هو ممكن كده وهو يروح يشوف أشغاله.
Mentor B: في اي ماشي طيب أنا حقولكوا حاجة لأن صح؟ قبل ما يطلعوها وبص
Mentor B: هو دلوقتي يعني الناس دي قبل ما اطلع اوبس كان الموضوع شوية قبل ما أغبس هو فين دول يطلعوا
Mentor B: قصدي فيابل فا الفكرة دي كان ناجح لأن هو يقدم طولت
Mentor B: ولا أي حد تاني من مع إن في الفترة بتاعت من واي ده
Mentor B: ده كان رغم كده ما حقاش نفس النجاح ولا عايز ينافس زي حتى موضوع أكشنز اللي يقدر يخلي يفهمني
Mentor B: محتاجين تركزوا من الإكسبيرينس عندنا هي يعني طبعا مهمة كل حاجة بس إكسبيرينس نفسها مهمة جدا
Mentor B: تقدر تنفذ بيها من غير ما تقدم يعني مثلا عندنا
Mentor B: كروت كوت طب ما هو فاهم الكوت فاهم الكود فاهم الكوت برضو بس المشكلة بقى إن هو نفذ خلى الحاجات دي بقدر ما انت تستخدمها
Mentor B: فاهمين فانزجت طبعا لمرافتها أنا حسبت الإيدز النجاة الأساسية
Mentor B: يعني النجاح المتعارف عليه يعني كلنا نختار قروض غالبا فيعني اكتسبها النجاح يعني
Mentor B: لان هو يغطي كل مشكلتي معضمها يعني فا
Mentor B: فدي نقطة مهمة يعني إيه حاجة يعني فكر في إنو
Mentor B: شيء مهم جدا نفس قوة الوزن وهذه أيضا. المشكلة هي المشكلة في نوع التانية، محتاجين نغوص عليها أوكي.
N.Learner B4: جدا. فرمان جدا جدا.
Mentor B: ماشي الوضع ندخل في حاجة ثانية. الشباب ننتقل ليهم.
N.Learner B4: فورمي. لا تمام جدا. أنا حشتغل على النقاط اللي انت ذكرتها كده وأبدأ عليها إن شاء الله.
Mentor B: بيتي الشباب.
Learner B3: أنا بالنسبة لي كنت ماشية في كذا أبرودج كده أول حاجة ركزت عليها إن أنا أركز على يعني أنا لما عملت أنا أولا الأسبوع ده كنت يعني مليان بال يوزر عملت مع كذا حد وكان
Learner B3: كان عندي تايلز يعني دخلت معاهم ميتينغز وكان ميتينغ سكب طويلة يعني
Learner B3: فدي أول حاجة وكمان عملت مع مين أنا كان فارق معايا إن أنا لما أجي أقدم يعني ممكن يبقى تحفة وعبقري من حتة يوزرز بس ما يبقاش منطقي أوي أو سهل خلينا نقول بالنسبة للمانتريز
Learner B3: ففكرة إن أنا ألاقي حل يكون موديل جراوند والإثنين يكونوا كان حاجة مركزة عليها الفترة دي مثلا يعني من.
Mentor B: والله الله ينعمك سميها طلعلك.
Learner B3: الله.
Mentor B: أفن.
Learner B3: شكرا والله حاجات مثلا أنا كنت ناوية فكرة البرتو تايب فعلا هو زي ما أنت بتقول هو ممكن يبقى فيها تغييرات. أنا كنت مثلا الحاجات اللي كنت شغالة عليها إن أنا أعمل تاب كده يكون فيه كل
Learner B3: بس لما دخلت مع منتر قالتلي إن ده مش حاجة تبقى منطقية أوي بالنسبالها لأن هي ممكن بعد كل سبرينت حاجات تتغير على حسب ال تيم
Learner B3: فمثلا تيم عمل شغل أكتر مثلا أو في تيم مثلا عنده في حتة معينة فالمفروض الكرايميست تقل أو تزيد. فلقيت هو لا فيبقى حلي حيتغير فبدل ما يبقى فور ويكس لأ يبقى ويك 1 سبرينت وحدة ويبقى في تشانس كدا لأي تشينجز في النص
Learner B3: فده بوينت بوينت وصلتلها. إن كل انترنشيب برضه ليها حاجة يعني في حاجات تنفع مع كل بس ممكن في حاجة ما تنفعش أوي في حاجة يعني تنفع مع انترنشيز ثانية لأ أو الإكزام برضه.
Mentor B: حلو.
Learner B3: بس أنا بصراحة فكرة دي إدتني إينسايد حاجات مختلفة قوي فحاسة إن أنا.
Mentor B: ويناوينا.
Mentor B: يعني تكلمي اكثر فيها مثلا.
Learner B3: يعني مثلا أنا الإكزام لما سألت في وحدة قالت لي إن هي عملت إكزامز اللي هو بحدد في الأول ليفيل يوزر فقالتلي أول 1 خدته
Learner B3: كان في أكتوري متقسم بطريقة حلوة يعني في الأول كان أمسك كيو بعد كده كان في كواستينز كولنغ وآخر بارت كان إن هو مش متذكرة بالظبط
Learner B3: أوكي فقالتلي الزمن اللي بعديه كان مختلف شوية كان ملي أمسك يو أكتر ومش عارفة إيه فبتقولي الأول كان أحلى كتير هي إضطرت تأجل حاجة كده يعني
Learner B3: فبس موضوع الانترفيوز ثوري إكزام الناس كتير قوي قالت إن هو طويل أوي،
Learner B3: وإن هو في مشكلة فأنا حاسة إن هو لا فعلا زي ما البنت قالت إن هو أول فيرجين من إكسام منطقي إن هو يقيس ليفيل فعلا بتاع يوزر
Learner B3: فبرت إكزام فيه أكتر.
Mentor B: طيب انت لقيتي مشاكل مكناش نوقفها قبل كده غير موضوع يعني طلعتلك مشاكل انت ما كنتش مكتشفها لحد ولا الاسبوع اللي فاتت يعني.
Learner B3: لا هو لغاية دلوقتي بس بالنسبة لهم إن هو طويل أوي تايم قليل وفكرة إن ممكن يبقى في فورماتس مختلفة. فأنا عايزة أسأل ليه في فورماتكس مختلفة.
Mentor B: حلو السؤال ده موفور محمد حاتم ولا انا.
Learner B3: أم.
Mentor B: ماشي أسألك سؤال تاني اللي اكتشفتيه عامله ازاي.
Learner B3: أكثري هم كانوا هل في الأول كلهم سواء أو
Learner B3: سألت اسئلة هي هي طويلة شوية بس هم كلهم بصراحة إنجلت معايا
Learner B3: في في حاجات كلهم اتفقوا فيها وفي حاجات لأ كانت سنة مختلفة يعني من الحاجات اللي كانت بتتقال إن مثلا هم عايزين يبقى جنبهم يعني
Learner B3: فمثلا يعني وحدة من لما دخلت معاها قالت إن هو يعني معلش ده شوية هي فكرة إن إحنا يعني معظمها كنا متفقين إن هي أصلا مش هدفها إن هو يدي كويس ثابتة يعني ده أصلا بخالف فكر نفسها
Learner B3: بس كنا اللي هو إزاي يكون في ميني كورسيس أو ميني فيديوس بس اللي هو تساعد بفكر مختلف ممكن ما تلاقوش أي كورس ثانية
Learner B3: برضه كان رأي وحدة قالتلي لأ ده برضه هي مش مع أصلا الفكرة ده قوي وحاسة إن هو سبونسيدينغ وهي شايفة أصلا فكرتها حلوة قوي كده
Learner B3: من غير أي بس عندهم حتة أو يوزرز عندهم حتة لأ إحنا عايزين حتة الزيادة دي أو حاجة تبقى جنبناكب شوية
Learner B3: فدي من ضمن إينسايدز.
Mentor B: طب هقولكوا حاجة يعني لا بد نتكلم يعني ما شاء الله عليكو ادبانسيد إينسايد كلها
Mentor B: وبرضه نفسك عملتيه بس خودي بالك من الحاجات دي وإنتي بتعمليها ان شاء الله لما.
Learner B3: أنا آسفة مأدوهين تاني فأنا بس عايزة أسمع الكلام بس ممكن بس دقيقة يعني محتاجة أنزل حالا.
Mentor B: حاضر ماشي يعني تنزلي بعد لما تدخلي يعني جوني تاني.
Learner B3: لأ أنا دقتين. ما حدخل تاني،
Mentor B: ماشي ماشي أوكي تفضل تفضل ماشي
Mentor B: الله.
Learner B6: مساء الخير، عليكم.
Mentor B: سامعك كده.
Learner B6: طيب أنا كنت بلعب على عدد وطبعا أطبق حتة النصائح اللي قلتهالي إن حطبها أكتر يعني.
Mentor B: إمم.
Learner B6: وهادي.
Mentor B: طب وايه بتاعتك إمم.
Learner B6: أنا بصراحة ما عملت ما عملتهاش تيست بس بحاول أنا ديفيلوب أكتر إيه.
Mentor B: ا.
Learner B6: بس حيجي منها يعني حيجي منها حاجة حلوة يعني.
Mentor B: طب بقية كانت عندكوا استراتيجي وحاجات مختلفة. هذا الاسبوع الفيدباك بتاعتك عليها والحاجات اللي تعلمتها منها.
Learner B6: حلو أوي أنا أنا في الاستراتيجي عندي
Learner B6: حابب ان انا اطبق يعني إيه يعني
Learner B6: أشوف أكتر كم مليوزر هم يستخدموا ال ال برودكت بتاعي
Learner B6: هو برودكت طبعا هو برودكت انتيرني سبرينس، فأنا أنا ححاول إن أنا أخلي بقدر الإمكان ال يوزرز أو إن هم يجربوا برودكت بتاعي
Learner B6: وأشوف النتائج وأظن أنا بعد كده أعدلها يعني أنا أعمل
Learner B6: كل كل بوينت أعمل ماركت دولي بوينت وأظن إن لو في مشكلة أو نقص أو حاجة.
Mentor B: حلو حلو طيب انت يعني كانت النقاط اللي تعلمتها منه انت خلصت التاستينغ ولسه اقصد.
Learner B6: لا لسه بسرعة.
Mentor B: أوكي ماشي لحد ما تخش يعني هي واحدة من الواقعة يعني
Mentor B: ندى
Mentor B: يعني لو انا اتكلم فيها اكثر اتكلم فيها أكثر هون يعني
Mentor B: قماش اوك طب إنت تعرفي تفتحي المايكرد وصلتي فين لإيه عشان أبدأ من النقطة اللي وصلت فيها ولا
Mentor B: المايك لسه مشغال
Mentor B: ولا مرة لا يوجد مشكلة خلاص احكيلكم على اتكلم في هو اكس لترستان
Mentor B: واحدة من الحاجات اللي انا بحبها شخصيا مثال عملي على ممكن تغير العينة. سامبل فكل هذه حاجات ابتدي من الفونديشن
Mentor B: انت بتعملوا لازم تكون موهاي كذا كم احتياط فأنا ممكن أبعتلكوا منها إحتياطات ال سيجمنت اللي انت بتاخد فيها ومنها ديزاين الإكسبين نفسها.
Mentor B: انا يمكن عملت قبل ان انجح قبل كده كان الهدف منه ان احنا نزود الريفينيوس
Mentor B: بتاعت يعني كناوس أد إي فكانت المشكلة وقتها
Mentor B: كانت المشكلة وقتها ان نحن اليوزي كانت في الامبودينغ وكانو اي حاجة
Mentor B: فاحنا بدلنا نعدل دوت بحيث ان احنا كان عندنا محتاجين نفهمه. اكتر عن البلاد محتاجين نفهمه. اكتر عن الميزات،
Mentor B: فلما دخل لما دخلوا عملنالو اصلا يعني تشرحله أكثر بدل ما ناخده في بحر الغد فاهمين مش فاهم هو اين
Mentor B: الذي هو يعني دي اول نقطه؟ اول شيء انا محتاج ان كل تيستينج يكون فيه لان هذا الذي حيز بيه
Mentor B: ولازم يعني تكون كافي جدا لأنه التجربة وممكن يخليك بايست يعني لازما يكون مترك
Mentor B: في اختصار يعني من الإكسبنس اللي تعلمتها مهمتك
Mentor B: فاينل متريك يعني أنا في النهاية مثلا مش عايز اقيس هو كم 1 لما جالي لما حطيت كم 1 مثلا تفاعل معاها
Mentor B: انت ما هو قصدي متفاعل معاه بس التفاعل معاه تترجم في
Mentor B: ماشي لا مش مش لازم تكون بيزنس مرتبط جدا مرتبط جدا بالبزنس يعني بيزنس هو مثلا ممكن يكون فاهمين
Mentor B: فدي نقطه مهمه جدا. يمكن دي اهم نقطة انا ما اعرفش انت عملتوا فأنا يعني من الفونديشنز خالص
Mentor B: نقطة تانية بقى وهي دي اللي تجبني الموضوع التاني أي أي دي عندك احتمال انت يعني حتقابلو بعدين أيرس
Mentor B: أكو ناس فول جيت فرنش
Mentor B: كنت بكلمكوا بقى التانيه النقطة الثانية، وهي تقول ان شاء الله تكون بتقعد مع ناس ليفيل عالية جدا يعني لو اشتغلت شغال في شركة كبيرة حتقعد مع ناس ليفين بس مش يعني مش
Mentor B: هم الناس اصلا ما بتتكلمش يقولوها بأرقام
Mentor B: معاهم فانت لازم تكون فاهم الناس دي جاي مهتمة بيك فأنت بتعمل بريسنتيشن
Mentor B: فهنا ينقلنا للحاجة الثانية اللي عايز أكلمكوا فيها انت بتقيس بتاع أي حاجة
Mentor B: يعني انت خلاص قلت لي أنا الراجل دوت أنا والله التجربة الفلانية دي زودت سبينس عندي
Mentor B: مثلا ب 20% هو بالنسبة له يعني يعني 20 في المية سوبسكيبشن يعني كم يعني دخلت الشبكة كام
Mentor B: فده النقطه مهمه جدا ان انت تكون قادر تحسب أي
Mentor B: عملتو بالنسبة دي نقطة مهمة جدا. وبالنسبة لهدف الشركة يعني مثلا 20 في المية طيب العشرين في المية إزاي من الناس اللي عندي
Mentor B: واجيب العشرين في المئه دول قعدوا هناك، فأنا عملت إكسبنس مثلا
Mentor B: فبالتالي بعدين النتيجة اللي هتحصل فأنا محتاج احسب الناس دي هتجيب ده كده التجربة دي بس في نفس الوقت
Mentor B: الناس دي لما تاخد اكسبانس حلو تحطم فمي أنا مش عارفة أي دولة مش عارفة عشان يوشحهولك فانا لازم أكون
Mentor B: من قياس الاشياء يعني بس دي نقطه مش عارف انا كدا تكلمت جاوبت على اسئلتكم ولا عندكم اي سؤال فيها
Mentor B: مشي مشي والله العظيم ما فيش حد عنده اسئلة. ماشي أوكي مش ميم إسلامية ماشي
Mentor B: مريم إنت كنت تيجي في البيت شكلي نسيتها أصلا بس حقول افتكره يعني.
Learner B3: شكرا.
Mentor B: نعم.
Learner B3: لا تمام أنا سامعة.
Mentor B: ماشي حيبقى بنتكلم فيه عشان أنا نسيت.
Learner B3: إن أنا كنت يعني بعمل مع كذا حد مع وكده.
Mentor B: ، افتكرت النقطة وانتي بتعملي انت مش عارفة ما شفتش الأسئلة اللي انت سألتها فيعني دي نقطة مهمة جدا لأن الأسئلة على فكرة عامة وانتو قاعدين معاهم لازم تكونوا فاهمين إن الراجل ده
Mentor B: يعني هو غالبا معظم الناس مؤدبين يعني هو لا يريد ان يقول لك حتى لو فيها عيوب يقول لك دي جميلة دي معرفش ده انتوا عاملين شغل عالي والله بس الحاجات دي
Mentor B: فنشاطاتي ان انا استخدم عندو هذه الأشياء أنا ممكن أبعت لكم حاجة في الكواليس أبعتلكم عليها
Mentor B: إن إنت تسأل أسئلة خلينا نقول صعوبة نية إن إنت تبدأ تقنش وتكشف الحقائق حتى لويس وحتى لو اليوزو ده مش عايز ولكن انت وحش
Mentor B: فاهمين في نقطة جدا فهي في علم وعلم سيكولوجي في مثلا انما ابدا اسأله
Mentor B: ما سألوش عن يعني خليني مثلا شايف حد فيكم. خذ تيستس بتاعة سيكولوجي اللي هو يبدا يسألك يقول لك اسئلة متخلفة دي لو انتصف وحشة من دول
Mentor B: انت اللي عايز تخليني بس هو بفضل يقيس بترتيبك للأشياء انت اصلا بتحب
Mentor B: فاهمين يعني مثلا كنت داخل قبل كده كان بيقولي هي أول حاجة من دول انت مفضلها
Mentor B: تمام ان انت تكون ما بتتكلمش فهو بيبدأ يرتب من الأسئلة بطريقة
Mentor B: يعني نيغاتيف كانت حبك للأشياء ولا لأ فاهمين شو فاهمين الليبر وصل لحد فين
Mentor B: فدي نقطة اللي بتشتغل عليه يعني حتسأل هلأ لازم تكون كاتب اللي هتقولو الو في نقطة
Mentor B: النقطة الثانية والمهمة جدا وهي ان اليوزرز حيقولولك أشياء مهمة جدا بس أشياء ممكن تخليك زي إيه لو كنت سألت الناس انتو عايزيني حصل اسرع
Mentor B: بس هو اكتشف ان هم الناس عايزين حاجة أسوأ فبالتالي حلو الكلام وهو ده مثال الأشخاص يعني يكون ده جدا يعني انت
Mentor B: فاهم ان هو سيقوله ده مش شرط هو لازم أسأله طب انت عملت دي ليه أفهم أكثر. حاولت ادخل. فده الحتة مريم
Mentor B: اعتقد ان انت ممكن تكوني عملتي منها يعني ما شفتش الأسئلة ولا هي بس هي دي ليكو ليكوا وللشباب يعني
Mentor B: تمام.
Learner B3: تمام أنا بجد اتفق قوي وحاسة فعلا إن أنا أصلا. لما كنت بدخل، ال
Learner B3: كنت بحاول على قد ما أقدر إننا ما أسأل وبحاول فعلا إن أنا أعرف بوسيتيف ستريس هو بصراحة يعني فعلا ايت تو سايتس قوي يعني.
Mentor B: حلوة حلوة يعني حاجة حلوة جدا
Mentor B: ماشي طيب ياسر يعني انتو كده معندكوش أي أسئلة صح؟ عندك أسئلة الشباب مهارات سعيده.
Learner B3: عايز أعرف برضه أكتر عن جامود
Learner B3: يعني الدم ودي حيمشي ازاي هيبقى إمتى.
Mentor B: ولا يشغلكم هم لما يحددوه واحنا نشتغل على فكره الان تفضلي.
Learner B3: لا. لا ولا حاجة.
Mentor B: ماشي ساقول لكم بس يعني انا شخصيا التي عملناها،
Mentor B: فهو مش مش حاجة نضيفة في السيكل دلوقتي.
Mentor B: نعم.
Learner B6: مثلا محتاجين جروب نوت بيرسونال أو فيدوال عشان محتاجين نبقى بروجكت تبقى كبير ويبقى حاجة قوية في سي في
Learner B6: ألريدي احنا متعاون فيعني شايف تبقى حاجة.
Mentor B: والله.
Learner B6: أم.
Mentor B: يعني ماشي لو اقتنعت بيها يعني يعني خلينا موجود و
Mentor B: لو هي لو هي تمام مشي كده أنا حقول اخش معايا كويس بس.
Learner B6: خلاص تمام احنا ممكن نتكلم في ظروف ونبعت لحضرتك ان احنا اتفقنا؟ ولا أي حاجة.
Mentor B: ماشي أوكي ماشي خلينا نعمل أكتيڤتي عايز أعملهم دلوقتي او خلينا نناقش الحاجة
Mentor B: والله كنت عايز النقاش الأول هو أنا كلمتك عن من هذه الاشياء هذه.
Learner B6: لا بس إحنا أنا نفسي أنا سمعت عنها هي يعني.
Mentor B: إمارة.
Learner B6: وسيف.
Mentor B: حلو حلو جامد جامد ياسر مدام مريم سمعت عنها وأنا قالت لأ
Mentor B: صح هذا مريم.
Learner B3: معلش إيه.
Mentor B: أم اسكون سمعت قبل ذلك.
Learner B3: يعني الجامعة بس ما وصلتش بيه قبل كده.
Mentor B: حلو ماشي الندى عايز اعرف مستواكم بس عشان أبدأ أتكلم منين عشان ما تكلمني في حاجات انتو عارفينها.
N.Learner B4: أنا بس مش سامعة. السؤال معلش تاني.
Mentor B: نعم.
N.Learner B4: عندي مش أحسن حاجة.
Mentor B: لا، لا عادي جويل باتريوس سمعتي عنها قبل كده.
N.Learner B4: الديسكرام أكيد والأجاييد أجايض، ولكن.
Mentor B: ألو.
N.Learner B4: في شغلي يعني.
Mentor B: ماشي حلو وبص شباب يعني أنا عندي بس سريعة كده عنها عشان دي نقطة مهمة
Mentor B: عامة يعني في بعد كده الجزء الأصعبوا اللي هو جزء من عندي يعني مش العالم مش متفق على كده يعني
Mentor B: مع الديفيلوبيس طبعا في طبعا العالم كله يستخدم ديسكاون
Mentor B: هو توينتي يعني حاجة مشهورة لو انت تشتغل فأنت شيك يعني
Mentor B: فاهمين بس هو مش شرطي يعني محتاجين ده اصدقائه عن مني مني حاجات زي كده كتير
Mentor B: والحاجات دي بتعتمد على ازاي. انت هتمام بتحكي ازاي هتمام هو في الأول بدل ما احنا نقعد نفضل ننتج الحاجة ونمشي بدل ما كانت الشركة تقعد مثلا عامل بودكت سنة ولا سنتين
Mentor B: السنتين. دول أنا آجيز هيقولك الماكر تغير وممكن يكون عادي اسبيشالي لو الماكر اللي احنا بنمشي في السريع
Mentor B: فأنت ساعتها خسرت كتير وفي نفس الوقت عندك مشكلة تانية لما انت نزلت يعني قعدت سنتين عمال فأنت عايز وتستثمر من الأول حلوين فكانت هنا هي تقلك لأ خلاص احنا
Mentor B: حنتبع بصمة الراية دي بتعتمد على حاليا بنعمله يعني
Mentor B: ده يميزها وان انت الماكيد بيتغير طول ما هو بيتغير. فإنت بتتغير معاه يعني انت بتاخد في شباك الماركت ففي فلوس بتجيلك حلو فدا ما يميزها. طب هل هل أحسن حاجة لا لأن هي في
Mentor B: فاهمين انزل مثلا شغال في مشروع طاقة نووية، فهو مش ينفع معلش أنزل الحاجة وبقوم بحاجات خطرة جدا.
Mentor B: زي أبليكيشن زي البنوك مثلا أبليكيشن بتاع مثلا يتصوب منه يعني فاهمين قصدي
Mentor B: فهي بتعتمد على طبيعة طبيعة البرج دي نقطة مهمة جدا فعشان بس ما يبقاش دائما إن إحنا
Mentor B: حلو طب دي اول نقطة النقطة الثانية في حاجة اسمها سبينت بلان في حاجة اسمها
Mentor B: يعني أنت في أول حاجة الأجندة كذا كذا أنت بتقول على حسب ما تحدد ال سبرينت على فكرة سبرينتس الشركة مسميها على إسم سبرينت الأول
Mentor B: الناس من الصدور الجيلي.
Mentor B: فالمهم إن السبرينت ده بتقول خلاص أنا كمدت كوميدت الشغل دوة حلو
Mentor B: فأنت بتحدده مع بتحدده عشان تعرفوا تدخلوا الكراستينج المناسبة حتى يعني فأنت لازم تكون دقيق جدا في الشغل ليدخل عشان ما تدخلش الكراسي، فإنت في الآخر تفشل إن إنت تسلم يعني
Mentor B: حلو فده بالنسبة للسكوم يعني الكنبة بتمشي عبارة عن كولمز قطاعتها تويوتة فبدل ما تقول لك
Mentor B: يعني هي كانت الفكرة الأول إنه الواحد بيعمل العربية في تويوتة ده 1 بيمسك العربية كلها
Mentor B: يعني يقول لك الكشافات ويحطها يروح يجيب العربية ويضعها فهي قالت والله لا ده الموضوع مكلف وقت كتير جدا كل 1 يروح لي هنا ويروح لهنا بتتعمل
Mentor B: فقلك.
Mentor B: فبعدين قال لك خلاص كل 1 يعمل بوسيز يعني وكل 1 يعمل حاجة وهو شاطب فيها
Mentor B: طبعا في نظريات تسمعوها عن اد ال سيستم دوت خوف الحياة البشر لأن هو الإنسان مبقاش يشوف النتيجة نتيجة شغله فبالتالي مش بحس باللي هو عمله لأنه هو بعيد التحول اللي ماشيين يعني بيعمل الحاجة اللي هو طول الوقت
Mentor B: بس هي بصيونسي شكل وهيب يعني كل حاجة فاللي بيركب الكشافة العربية بيركبه اللي بيركب الوادي بتاع العربية بيركبه
Mentor B: ده بالنسبة للكنبة يعني الفلسفة اللي هو كأنها بتمشيز وانت بتحط ليميت في كل في كل في ستاج ان هي مش هينفع مثلا بتعدي على ديفيلوبمينت تيستينج ديبلايمنت هكذا يعني
Mentor B: فليخلص الا بيخلص، فهذه بالنسبه للكنبة
Mentor B: طبعا أنا مش حقدر أشرحها لأن هي ده طبعا كبير جدا وإن شاء الله أنا
Mentor B: دلوقتي مش حيسفنا نمشي. بس أنا بقولكم الين بوينس يعني بس تكونوا فاهمين
Mentor B: نرجع ثاني لو انت بتبدأ في وجودك مانجمنت
Mentor B: مانجمنت عشان تاخد تكبر شوية يعني انت حتلاقي معظم فيها عشان تتعلم عشان تتعلم
Mentor B: فاهمين وبعد ما بتتعمق انت في الديسكافي وبتاخد الديسكوفري معاك يعني تبقى محظوظ لو انت لقيت حاجة بتمنج ال ديسكوفر ديليفيري سوا ماشي ماشي
Mentor B: وكل عام لما تكبر في السينيورتي بتركز أكثر على السكابري وال ديليفيري لانه هو الناس بتعتبه جزء وحش مش حلو لأنه جزء
Mentor B: فده بالنسبة للجزء بتاع ديليفيري فإنت بقى تركز على بتتقاس
Mentor B: بتاعته في بتخش تشوف بتقول ويعني اللي عملوا مبارح وإيه اللي حيعملوه النهارده ماشي انا اتفضل
Mentor B: طب بس طب بص يا ندى. طب هل 5 دقايق بس ناخد ال أكتيڤيتي سريع يعني حقطع ال عشان المهم
Mentor B: ليتم بالضبط يشتغلوا عليه
Mentor B: شايفين مسكين كده.
Learner B3: باينة كده.
Mentor B: أم أوكي
Mentor B: اسامة؟ انا دخلت على جمول اجبلكم هنشوف دلوقتي الجب اللي نازلة انتو خدتوا سكيلز بتاعتها ولا كده
Mentor B: أي شي تعالوا نشوف هم طالبين بسكريبشن
Mentor B: نحن عايزين نتوسط إنتو عملتوا الكلام ده الكلام ده عملتوا الكلام ده
Mentor B: عملت الكلام دوت ذي فاين بلاتفورم كباب ديسيز أند غوت عملتوها
Mentor B: الحتة لسه كنت حتكلم فيها اهو دي يعني بيت الدين
Mentor B: بقية الحاجات لا دي حاجات مانجمنت شوية في كوليبريشن ليد
Mentor B: عشان يقول عايز حد كبير تمن سنين يعني احنا اخدنا جوب يعني 8 سنين يعني يا دوبك الإكسبنس بتاعتي يعني انا اجيبه بالعافيه.
Mentor B: إنتو أخدتوا بقى وتبعتوهالي مناسبة لينا طيب الهدف ده إنه إنتو
Mentor B: تعرفوا انتو فين من المؤكد دلوقتي انتوا تعلمتوا خلاص عشان تشتغلوا كبولة إحنا دخلنا عشوائيا مش محضر مثلا
Mentor B: لايف تايم إل تي في ماشي
Mentor B: الإثنين دول معناهم تركز عالقسم بتاعته
Mentor B: عندنا تاني عندنا فاينانش عندنا أوف إنجاجمنت مانجمنت يعني
Mentor B: دي حاجات معينة تشتغلوا عليها هناك يعني بس برضه يعني إنتو بتغطوا معظم إحساسكم وعايز اسمها كده.
N.Learner B4: إحساسنا عظم طبعا.
Learner B3: بجد يعني.
Mentor B: إنتو كده أنا عايزكم بقى تدوروا
Mentor B: على كل الشباب عشان مش موجودين بقولولهم نعم.
Learner B3: لا لا مع حضرتك.
Mentor B: فأنتو بصو انتوا كده خلاص يعني إنتو كده متعلمين كل حاجة
Mentor B: انتو بس هتلاقو بس باقي وبس ده بس لو احتجتوا اي حاجة بعد كده بس إنتو الحمد لله يعني احنا غطينا معظم الحاجات اللي
Mentor B: يعني تغطي 70 80 في المية منه وعادي لحد دلوقتي في جو بوستز مغطي المية في المية بتاعتها فانت بتتعلم الحاجات المطلوبة دي في جو مناسبة ليك في جو لا
Mentor B: يقول لي أنا شايف ان انا
Mentor B: تمام انا هنا ارى هذه مناسبة لي أنا أقصد، حاجة، اتفقنا؟
Learner B3: أرسطيف.
Mentor B: ماشي مبسوطينت ولا إيه.
Learner B3: صراحة أنا عاجبني قوي وحاسة يعني لا استفدت كتير
Learner B3: وأنا أصلا يعني قوي يعني أنا حاسة لأ يعني ستارت حلو قوي لي.
Mentor B: حلو أوي حلو
Mentor B: يا شباب يعني موفقين ان شاء الله ويعز كل أسبوع بقى تكملوا ما توقفوش حتى لو تنزلكوا عشان هم يقفلوا وما توقفوش انتو الشغل على بوجيتس اللي معاكوا تواصلوا معاي لو في حاجة واقف قدامكوا ويلا هود ويكيند.
Learner B3: ثانك يو جدا ليكوا وبجد الفيدباك كان فانيبل قوي قوي.
Mentor B: شكرا شكرا يا مي.
N.Learner B4: يعني تعلمنا منك أكتر ما تعلمنا من تصفيس كلها.
Learner B3: حياك الله.
N.Learner B4: كلت يو يعني الصراحة.
Mentor B: شكرا شكرا إن شاء الله.
Mentor B: شكرا شكرا يا هلا شكرا
Mentor B: ماشي يا شباب، ويكيند كده وان شاء الله الاحد الجاي نحاول ندخل سوا كده مع بعض كده نشوف وصلتوا لايه ماشي.
Learner B3: إن شاء الله.
Mentor B: شكرا.
Learner B3: باي باي.
Mentor B: طيبة.